[Music]
hello what up Candace what's going on yo
I got somebody should be my name is
Brianna Daniel didn't I attend a NASCAR
changing the game over I'll choose to
play basketball she's a huge fan enjoy
it ain't gonna be pretty have you been
doing a little surprise for ya man of
course I appreciate so I can't be posted
on the details and then we go from there
dedication patience sub or my sacrifice
I'm doing away don't wait told you that
I wasn't black now you hear what I've
been saying
[Music]
Brianna Dennis a lifetime Hooper she
played her way through high school and
junior college walked on at Norfolk
State with the fluoride she lost her
mother to breast cancer but instead of
tearing her down and push the forward
now she's out here on the track crossed
over from the court she's already made
NASCAR history in the pit and isn't done
yet she's black she's female
she's putting work
coach or it's definitely like how my
basketball coaches weren't like he's
hard on me to even know I'm first seems
like I you know I thought she was
bullish he said when I brought you in
here I saw you you really want to do
this and I was like yeah
rata made history by becoming the first
female african-american pit crew member
she's 24 years old
front and center changing more than just
tires good job that's a good that's a go
go go god I didn't know anything about
NASCAR I was sitting here looking like
people really enjoy driving a circle was
like or living in they're going too fast
like I would never
he needs a throw bags she taught me how
to play bass but you know that right how
got my start you know mom and dad didn't
play basketball
[Music]
are you been with having good me and
just live in the race life how does that
sound right it is way different from
basketball you first told me exactly
I met Briana when we went on a
recruiting trip to Norfolk State
University we're always looking for big
strong male football players and she
comes
so walks in the gym I saw these guys
these big football players I was the
only girl that tried out and I could
feel people like saying how women really
don't make it like that in the sport and
I was like dude why are you telling me
this because that's not gonna stop me
from performing the way that I do you
know when I first got into the sport I
was coaching training working with
mechanics they know all about the tools
of the trade one of the things that they
couldn't adjust to was to perform under
pressure
the athletes know how to perfect and
it's just a situation where we had to
teach them now how to use the tools and
how to make all that work to have a fast
pit stop you know they come in and they
don't know anything about it the first
time I went over the wall was the
weekend in Dover when I like made
history I had two races back-to-back one
of those races when I had like jumped
over the wall too soon
the official came over and was like yeah
we had a early jump and I was like
thanks oh he can't drive he was like no
he had to sit here for like a lap or two
I'm like oh my god dude I'm so sorry
like
[Music]
he said that was a very interesting day
you know just people not used to seeing
a round girl like myself just walking
around the track
I can feel people like break their necks
like when I walk by or they have shades
on and they act like they're not looking
but some people I guess they think their
tents dark enough but I can see their
eyes like you know things like this dude
is try me like staring at my credentials
making sure I belong at the strike oh
well I belong I got like a real nasty
look one day I'm like hey how you doing
today and the guy looked at me was like
you know I'm like well dang I just
walked away I'm like okay well that's
somebody who's stuck in their old ways I
remember seeing a couple of tweets why
don't you want to join a racist for it
know like what but Briana Vaughn said
but let's be real race car teams are
still dominated by white Nick and on
race day the crowd still looks like this
but Briana Daniels is living that racela
strong black woman forcing this
old-school sport for Freddy's footage
one in the beginning all eyes were on me
you know been in my position it's not
easy at all my mom is a she's the reason
why I go so hard and that's where a lot
of my motivation comes from you know
just seeing her battle with breast
cancer and just
sorry just ain't hurt about it with
breast cancer most of her life she just
taught me to be strong as a person you
know seeing her go through something
like that and still she took us
basketball games football games she was
there cheering us on
she was Wonder Woman superwoman you know
so like whenever I feel like giving up
and anything in life like I always thing
about her that plays a huge part in me
being able to deal with the stuff that
I've been dealing with you know in the
beginning of the season like before I
did my first race in February I got a
call like Briana is everything all right
because I've been getting phone calls
from people saying that I think they're
looking at trick tweets and they're just
worried about you and I'm like dang my
people are really looking at my social
media like that I said it's hard being a
black woman in this sport and I was like
wow that's like the moment I realized
people were actually planted into my
stuff
three years from now hopefully we can
talk about her being on the cover but
that is gonna take a lot of hard work on
her part she has a long way to go I
still have more barriers and doors to
break down got to get my first win
hopefully we will have more diversity
and more minorities in the sport to see
if my face in like a kid's textbook if
they can read about something and
they're like hey mommy there's this girl
she made history you know it's the first
african-american female it's hard
changing I want to be like her when I
grew up you know I just sparked that in
their mind I know when like another
black female joins NASCAR I could just
take her under my wing you know give her
the rundown of it all
Mike look girl you got to be yourself in
this sport can't take nothing for nobody
just be yourself coming here work hard
do what you got to do I'll be a day -
see right there yes
[Music]
[Music]
so we usually start on this side all
right
as the car is running out we're jumping
off the wall and running in front of the
car all right let's do it
yes definitely getting the penalty
[Music]
[Music]
you're running yeah I wanna get a
Candace let's do it okay in basketball I
mean we have our own league that's
carved out we've been playing for 22
years and I think we're still trying to
gain respect if you could say anything
to the casual fan that's watching a
NASCAR that's like man women can't
change tires yeah like what would you
say just give everybody you know the
fair chance to prove themselves you
can't just go in there judging someone
because they're male or female I have
learned so much today it has been an
honor you've been an inspiration I'm
still at a loss for words and I'm
sitting here with my idol I appreciate
it okay yes it is so nice meeting you
women constantly have to prove that you
deserve to be there but once you get
that respect and you know people
acknowledge it you're not just there as
like the token figurative realize you're
good and she'll set the bar and other
woman would follow and you know open up
the doors for things that women didn't
have a place for years ago this is
Carmelo Anthony thanks for watching to
meet more heroes go to be really to
report
[Music]